>> PETE BUTTIGIEG, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
BUS AND TRAIN SERVICE ALSO
AFFECTED AS THE STORM THREATENS
TO MAKE TRAVEL IMPOSSIBLE IN
SOME AREAS TODAY.
YOUR TOP CONCERN RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, THE TOP CONCERN IS
ALWAYS SAFETY.
ON THE AVIATION SIDE, OUR
NATIONAL AVIATION SYSTEM IS
OPERATING BUT IT'S OPERATING
UNDER ENORMOUS STRAIN.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS MULTIPLE ISSUES
ACROSS DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
AIRSPACE.
IN THE NORTHWEST, SNOW IS
AFFECTING SEATTLE, PORTLAND AND
THAT AREA.
ON THE EAST COAST DOWN TOWARD
ATLANTA, WIND IS THE MAIN ISSUE.
AND AS YOUR CORRESPONDENT
REPORTED IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
COUNTRY, IT'S REALLY ABOUT THAT
FRIGID TEMPERATURE YOU'RE
SEEING.
THAT LIMITS THE GROUND CREW FROM
YOU OPERATING.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF WINTER
WEATHER GEAR BUT THERE'S ONLY SO
LONG THOSE WORKERS CAN BE ON THE
GROUND SERVICING BEFORE IT'S A
SAFE ISSUE.
I CONSIDER ANYTHING ABOVE ABOUT
2% TO BE A HIGH RATE OF
CANCELLATION AND AS IT WAS
REPORTED TODAY, WE'RE ALREADY
ABOVE THE NUMBER OF
CANCELLATIONS WE SAW YESTERDAY.
SO THE AVIATION PICTURE, YOU'LL
SEE A LOT OF DISRUPTIONS.
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO STAY IN
CLOSE TOUCH WITH THEIR AIRLINE
BUT FROM A SAFETY PERSPECTIVE,
THE THING YOU'LL MOST WORRIED
ABOUT IS THE ROADWAYS.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF DRIVERS MAYBE
NOT USED TO DRIVING IN WINTER
CONDITIONS, TRAVELING TO A PLACE
YOU'RE NOT USED TO DRIVING TO
VISIT RELATIVES.
I KNOW WE ALL WANT TO GET TO OUR
LOVED ONES FOR THE HOLIDAYS BUT
PLEASE, PLEASE PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION TO WHAT LOCAL
AUTHORITIES ARE SAYING.
IF THAT YOUR SAYING IT'S NOT
SAFE TO DRIVE, IT'S NOT SAFE TO
DRIVE.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH YOU WANT TO
BE QUICKLY TO YOUR LOVED ONES,
MAKE SURE YOU GET THERE SAFE.
>> I'M GLAD YOU'RE STRESSING THE
ROAD BECAUSE THAT'S HOW MOST
PEOPLE TRAVEL IS ON THE ROADS.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY AIR TRAVEL,
THOUGH THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS URGING
AMERICANS TO STAY OFF THE ROADS
IN PLACES WHERE THE WEATHER IS
BAD, AS YOU JUST HAVE AS WELL.
THE CANCELLATIONS LIKELY TO PUSH
SOME FAMILIES TO DRIVE EVEN MORE
AND TO DRIVE HOME FOR THE
HOLIDAYS INSTEAD.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT TO HEED THE
WARNINGS THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
GIVING AND THAT YOU JUST GAVE
HERE ON OUR AIR AS WELL?
>> WELL, LOTS OF THINGS ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO US AROUND THE
HOLIDAYS.
OUR TRADITIONS, OUR LOVED ONES.
BUT OF COURSE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS TO BE SAFE, TO BE ALIVE
AND WELL FOR YOUR LOVED ONES AND
THAT MEANS MAKING SMART CHOICES
WHEN IT COMES TO DRIVING
CONDITIONS AND ROAD CONDITIONS.
IF THE INDICATION FROM THE
FORECASTS AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES
IS THAT YOU CAN DRIVE BUT YOU
NEED TO DO IT WITH CAUTION, TAKE
THOSE STEPS.
WE'VE GOT RECOMMENDATIONS ON OUR
WEB SITE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT WITH LOCAL
AUTHORITIES, TOO, ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE SURE YOUR CAR IS EQUIPPED
FOR WINTER WEATHER, THAT YOU ARE
USING A CAR SEAT IN A WAY THAT'S
SAFE WITH THE BLANKET AND
JACKETS ON THE OUTSIDE OF THE
STRAPS, NOT THE INSIDE, THOSE
KIND OF STEPS THAT WILL MAKE IT
SAFE.
BUT IF THEY'RE SAYING DON'T
DRIVE, DON'T DRIVE.
THE PRESIDENT INDICATED HOW
SERIOUS THIS IS.
WE'RE SEEING THINGS LIKE I-90
ACTUALLY CLOSED OUTRIGHT IN
PARTS OF SOUTH DAKOTA AND
MINNESOTA LAST I SAW.
THAT IS NOT A STEP THAT
AUTHORITIES TAKE LIGHTLY,
CLOSING AN INTERSTATE.
YOU REALLY WANT TO PAY ATTENTION
TO LOCAL WARNINGS BECAUSE THESE
TEMPERATURES THAT WE'RE SEEING,
ESPECIALLY IN THE MIDDLE PART OF
THE COUNTRY, THAT CAN TURN AN
ORDINARY FENDER BENDER INTO
SOMETHING MUCH MORE DANGEROUS.
>> I KNOW YOU'RE THE
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY BUT I
ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE THE TWO
DO CONNECT.
CRAIG MILLER, PROFESSOR OF
ELECTRICAL AND COMPUTER
ENGINEERING AT CARNEGIE MELLON
UNIVERSITY, HE TALKED ABOUT THE
STRESS ON OUR ELECTRICAL GRIDS
AND THE STRESS THAT WORKERS
CAN'T GET OUT THERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT, IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME, IT HAS TO WARM UP A
LITTLE FOR THEM TO GET OUT THERE
AND THE STRESS IT PUTS ON THE
SYSTEM WHEN THE POWER COMES BACK
ON BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS THEIR
POWER ON AND WHAT HAVE YOU, CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THAT?
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET TOO FAR
OUTSIDE OF MY EXPERTISE BUT THIS
IS ANOTHER AREA YOU WANT TO PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT LOCAL
AUTHORITIES AND LOCAL UTILITIES
ARE SAYING.
JUST AS WE HAVE EXTRAORDINARY
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS, WHO ARE
EVEN IN THESE EXTREME CONDITIONS
HELPING YOU GET TO WHERE YOU
NEED TO BE AND GETTING PACKAGES
TO WHERE THEY NEED TO BE.
WHEN YOU DO HAVE THESE OUTAGES,
IT EXTRAORDINARY WHAT THE LINE
WORKERS AND OTHERS GO THROUGH IN
ORDER TO QUICKLY RESTORE POWER.
IMPORTANT TO LISTEN TO ANY LOCAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS ABOUT HOW TO MAKE
THINGS A LITTLE BIT EASIER FOR
THEM.
EVERYONE'S PRIORITY IS TO KEEP
EVERYBODY UP AND RUNNING AND
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
>> AS A FORMER MAYOR, I KNOW UP
WOULD KNOW HOW TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
UP HAD TO DEAL WITH THAT IN THAT
ROLE AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND MERRY CHRISTMAS TO
YOU AND YOURS.
>> THANK YOU.
TAKE CARE.
>> LET'S GO TO REPORTER JEREMY
PIERRE, WHO IS LIVE FOR US IN
MEMPHIS, TENNESSEE.
WIND CHILLS CLOCKED AT NEGATIVE
18.
THAT'S NOT NORMAL FOR MEMPHIS.
HOW ARE THINGS GOING THERE?
>> Reporter: DEFINITELY NOT A
TYPICAL DAY HERE IN THE CITY OF
MEMPHIS AND IT'S SHOWING WITH
THE DRIVERS FOR SURE.
WE'RE ON WALNUT GROVE, WHICH IS
VERY POPULAR FOR PEOPLE TO GET
TO AND FROM WORK AND ALREADY WE
HAVE SEEN PEOPLE BE DEFEATED BY
THIS HILL HERE IN FRONT OF HOPE
CHURCH IN WALNUT GROVE IN THE
CITY OF MEMPHIS.
WE ACTUALLY SAW ABOUT TEN CARS
THAT EITHER HAD BEEN ABANDONED
OR WRECKED.
YOU CAN SEE IT RIGHT HERE.
ALREADY THIS MORNING IN THIS
SECTION WE HAVE SEEN FOUR CARS
SPIN OUT OF CONTROL.
THAT CAR RIGHT THERE, THAT
VEHICLE, THAT SUV IS THE LONE
ONE THAT IS JUST STUCK.
IT CAN'T MOVE BECAUSE OF THE
ICE.
NOT ONLY IS THE ICE ON THIS ROAD
HARD TO DRIVE ON BUT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY IMPOSSIBLE TO WALK
ON.
I GOT A CHANCE MYSELF TO SEE FOR
MYSELF THAT IT IS ICE.
ICE FOR SURE.
FOR THE MOST PART PEOPLE ARE
HAVING TROUBLE GOING UP THE HILL
AND ALSO DOWN THE HILL AS YOU
SEE THIS CRASHED OUT CAR RIGHT
HERE.
ALSO WITH PEOPLE COMING DOWN
THIS HILL RIGHT HERE, PEOPLE ARE
ENDING UP THAT HILL FOR SURE.
SO I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
SEVERAL SOURCES AND WITH LOCAL
HOSPITALS.
THANKFULLY NO ONE HAS SHOWN UP
TO A HOSPITAL THIS MORNING DUE
TO INJURIES BECAUSE OF ANY OF
THE CAR CRASHES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED OR BEING SPUN OUT OF
CONTROL HERE IN THE CITY OF
MEMPHIS.
DEFINITELY NOT A TYPICAL DAY.
IT'S COLD, EXTREMELY COLD, NOT
WHAT YOU'RE USED TO IN THIS NECK
OF THE WOODS IN THE MID SOUTH
AREA AND NOT A TYPICAL DRIVING
DAY FOR ANYONE WHO HAS TO GO TO
OR FROM WORK.
>> MEMPHIS, THIS IS NOT YOUR
WEATHER.
STAY HOME.
>> AND JEREMY, DO NOT WALK ON
THAT ROAD.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE THE ICE,
RIGHT?
IF YOUR CAMERAMAN WILL SHOW US
THAT SHOT AGAIN RIGHT NEXT TO
YOU, YOU CAN SEE THE ICE ON THE
ROAD.
DON'T DO IT, JEREMY.
>> Reporter: YOU CAN SEE THE
ICE.
LOOK, I'M TOUCHING IT.
UP SEE HOW SLICK MY HAND IS
RIGHT HERE.
IT IS JUST SLIDING, SLICK AND
SLIDING.
WHOO!
>> YEAH, THAT'S THE RIGHT WORD,
JEREMY, THAT'S THE TRUEST THING
THAT ANYBODY HAS SAID ON THIS
SHOW ALL MORNING.
>> WHOO, WHOO!
>> NOW THAT IS A GOOD REPORT.
WE WANT TO HEAD NOW TO DENVER
WHERE TEMPERATURES PLUMMETED
OVERNIGHT AND WIND CHILLS ARE 13
DEGREES BELOW ZERO RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S WHERE WE FIND LUCY
KAFANOV.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
HOW ARE PEOPLE HOLDING UP AFTER
SOME RECORD DROPS IN TEMPERATURE
THERE?
>> Reporter: YEAH, DON.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
NOT A GREAT MORNING CONSIDERING
HOW PAINFUL IT IS TO BE STANDING
OUT HERE.
WE DID CONSIDER TRYING TO FIND
FOLKS TO ASK THEM HOW THAT YOUR
HOLDING UP BUT THANKFULLY MOST
PEOPLE SEEM TO BE HEEDING THE
ADVICE OF AUTHORITY AND STAYING
OUT OF THIS TERRIBLE, BITTER
COLD.
NOW COLORADO IS USED TO COLD
WINTERS.
WE'RE USED TO SNOW, WE'RE USED
TO THE TEMPERATURES DROPPING BUT
OF COURSE THE SWIFTNESS WITH
WHICH THIS ARCTIC BLAST CAME
BARRELLING THROUGH WAS JUST
REMARKABLE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
75-DEGREE TEMPERATURE SWING FROM
ROUGHLY 50 DEGREES ON WEDNESDAY
WHEN I WAS ON AIR TO MINUS 24
DEGREES THURSDAY MORNING AND
THOSE NUMBERS DON'T DO JUSTICE
TO HOW IT ACTUALLY FEELS TO THE
HUMAN BODY, TO THE SKIN OUTSIDE.
WIND CHILLS OF NEGATIVE 60,
APPROACHING NEGATIVE 60 IN SOME
PARTS OF COLORADO.
THAT'S THE KIND OF CONDITION
THAT COULD CAUSE FROSTBITE TO
EXPOSED SKIN IN MINUTES.
FOLKS ARE URGED TO STAY INDOORS.
COLORADO'S GOVERNOR ACTIVATED
THE NATIONAL GUARD TO HELP WITH
THE EXTREME COLD WEATHER
CONDITIONS WE DID SEE THE
MASSIVE DENVER COLISEUM OPEN UP
TO GET OUT OF THE COLD.
THERE WAS SO MUCH DEMAND, THEY
HAD TO OPEN UP TWO MORE CENTERS
TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF THE
UNCOMFORTABLE, PAINFUL
CONDITIONS.
MOST OF THE CITY IS HUNKERING
DOWN.
WE ARE SEEING CAR TRAFFIC AND
THERE IS GOOD NEWS ON THE
HORIZON FOR US.
WE'RE EXPECTING THESE COLD WIND
CHILLS UNTIL ABOUT 11 A.M. LOCAL
TIME BUT THEN THE TEMPERATURES
WILL FINALLY START CLIMBING
ABOVE ZERO.
WE'VE HAD 35 HOURS OF
TEMPERATURES BELOW ZERO.
WE COULD BE BACK TO REGULAR
TEMPERATURES BY CHRISTMAS.
>> LUCY KAFANOV, THANK YOU